bruno le maire s'est il un peu avancé en
annonçant le rebond économique tant
attendue pour 2021 et un objectif de 6%
de croissance c'est à peine plus que les
prévisions de l'insee ou de la banque de
france qui table tous les deux sur 5 %
pour 2021
mon pour calmer les esprits sachez que
les chiffres pour 2020 pas encore
définitif tablent eux sur une récession
entre 9 et 11% et que donc même si les
objectifs de 2021 soit atteint les
niveaux d'avant crise ne seront pas
retrouvés cette année
mais revenons à notre annonce de
croissance de bruno le maire écran crime
et ou objectif atteignable en fait y'a
pas de secret tous les experts le disent
tout va dépendre de la pandémie et du
vaccin
si les mesures sanitaires peuvent être
mauvais si tous les commerces sont
ouverts si la consommation repart et si
le réel impact du virus ne se fait pas
sentir sur le tard ou plus dur est
devant nous on l'a entendu et réentendu
de la part du gouvernement ou même si
dans ces caches
car si toute l'économie est encore pour
le moment perfusé à coups de milliards
et aides en tous genres que se
passera-t-il lorsque les dispositifs
d'urgence seront levés les entreprises
tiendront tel le coup et arriveront
elles à rembourser les fameux p geo
prêts garantis par l'état elles sont
tout de même 600 83000 en avoir
contracté l'assureur euren hermès à
d'ores et déjà avancé des chiffres qui
pourraient casser l'optimisme de bruno
le maire
les faillites d'entreprises pourrait
s'élever à 50 milles en 2021 et plus de
60000 en 2022
[Musique]